[Music]  earlier this week I unveiled a superhero  suit that the people at iron head  Studios made specifically for me they're  the team that created Ben Affleck's  Batman suit so many other iconic  superhero costumes I decided to go out  well actually I'll show you from the  show just the other night take a look  I'm sorry that's just before I put on  the suit  any who's I really love that suit it's  fantastic so I thought in the spirit of  comic-con and really getting into it I  should walk around San Diego and show it  off a little bit I just did that we  brought a camera crew here's just a  little taste take a look  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  thank you  [Applause]  please let's do it really right there  I'll touch it myself  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you